according to author David Robson we're
not always as smart as we think we are
psychological research suggests that
greater intelligence education and
expertise might actually amplify our
errors consider this question how many
animals of each species did Moses take
on the ark the answer of course is zero
it was Noah not Moses who was supposed
to have built the ark but many
intelligent people get this wrong
they are cognitive misers they are
capable of intelligent reasoning but
they don't apply that brainpower
effectively instead relying too much on
their gut feelings cognitive misers
leanness can cause us to be swayed by
irrelevant information and our own
feelings for example leading us to poor
financial decisions when buying a house
it can also explain why apparently
intelligent people can fall for fake
news if they rely too much on the gist
rather than the details of a statement
sometimes thanks to the emotional pull
of an argument we think in a very
one-sided manner so Arthur Conan Doyle
is the perfect example of motivated
reasoning now he was obviously an
incredibly intelligent man he was a
doctor and also wrote all of the
Sherlock Holmes books where he really
shows a very clear understanding of what
logical deductions should be but in his
own private life Arthur Conan Doyle was
not nearly so rational he had a very
strong emotional belief in spiritualism
and often visited fraudulent mediums now
Arthur Conan Doyle's friends which
included Harry Houdini the illusionist
often tried to persuade him that he was
wrong and to show him the evidence that
he was being scammed by these people but
Arthur Conan Doyle just didn't believe
their arguments so for instance he would
try to bring in the latest physics on
the electromagnetic field to explain how
fairies might exist but just appeared in
another wavelength you may not believe
in fairies but motivated reasoning can
lead to polarized political views it may
also allow you to rationalize poor
business ventures or a failing love
affair you may hope that education or
professional expertise would protect you
from error but these can also backfire
after years of experience in a job
experts for instance might begin to act
on autopilot and that automatic
decision-making can sometimes miss vital
information this may explain a terrible
case from 2004 when a man called Brandon
Mayfield was accused of conducting the
Madrid bombings
now Brandon Mayfield had not left the
USA during that time and yet the FBI's
fingerprint examiner's still accused him
of the crime the Spanish police had
found a fingerprint on a plastic bag
near the scene of the crime
now the FBI had put that into their
computers and they had found about 20
candidates who might have made the match
and when they looked at Brandon
Mayfield's they were sure that they were
identical
when you look at the fingerprints there
are actually some very important
differences that they had completely
missed but thanks to the curse of
expertise they were susceptible to
confirmation bias so they only saw the
bits that matched and were completely
blind to the bits that didn't match
sometimes smart people can act stupidly
thanks for the people who are around us
a sense of conflict and competition
within a group can actually reduce each
team members problem-solving skills and
creativity even just one or two arrogant
team members can completely ruin the
group dynamic and reduce the performance
of the whole team one study found that
people's individual IQ levels actually
drop when they filled in competition
with others just think of Iceland's
victory in the 2016 euro championships
now Iceland is a tiny country compared
to the rest of Europe it really doesn't
have a huge pool of talent and yet they
performed extraordinarily well and in
fact they are humiliated the England
football team by defeating them despite
all of our really top tier players now
this is an example of the too much
talent effect because England were so
many star players really struggled to
have a cohesive group dynamic there were
too many egos vying for attention
luckily there are things that you can do
to avoid these thinking traps for
example you can try arguing against
yourself consider your initial gut
reaction and then deliberately try to
think from the opposite point of view
another technique you can use is called
self distancing step out of your shoes
for a second and think about your issue
from an outside perspective or you might
try mental time travel imagine yourself
in a month or a year's time looking back
at your decision lastly why not try
fine-tuning your emotional awareness
being able to label our feelings helps
us to control them various studies have
shown that this simple technique has
actually reduced the emotional responses
and made people less biased
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon